[Music]  he's about to land in 15 minutes i'm  yeah i'm super super nervous right now  it's been two years i'm freaking out  [Music]  in the next 90 days kobe and i have to  figure out if our chemistry is still  there  i have to introduce him to our son cobin  and work on our relationship as parents  it's a lot  what if my family doesn't like him he  doesn't like them and he doesn't like  america  [Music]  okay his plans his plane is in his  plane's there  oh my god hold on  oh my god  i'm so nervous  seriously i'm so nervous i'm freaking  out  just like i haven't seen them i don't  know how it's gonna go you know what i  mean like  like i'm excited i'm very excited but  like the nerves are like getting to me  you know it's been a long time  [Music]  oh my god  [Music]  oh my god  [Music]  [Music]  [Laughter]  huh  [Music]  you